and we say hello to Christian Laettner
the hall of famer 2-ton n-c-double-a
champion Duke former NBA player how are
you I'm doing great but wait what why
why are we talking here we could be over
there playing ping-pong but we can still
play ping-pong during the commercial
break you want to play against our best
McLovin who did i smack around last time
I don't know if that was a result well
I'm ready to take on the number three
seed because I'm number one he was too
ok don't you ever let the company on the
competitiveness you know wrestler serve
for serving people are pawns - it's fun
ok is the story correct that when you're
on the Dream Team you beat Michael
Jordan in ping-pong time I just I just
wanna I just want to make sure that it's
a whole new audience here you're right a
new audience so we got to go through it
again yes we do and then we could talk
about the shot against Kentucky and you
know stepping on a guy's chest we can do
all of those things to get alright so
tell me you beat Jordan in ping-pong and
then his reaction when you beat him in
ping-pong was and I beat David Stern and
over the years I've heard through the
rumor mill that Jordan had like someone
go out and buy a ping-pong table and
take it up to his room
yes so he could practice now I don't
know if all that's true I never heard
that
until the rumor mills and I didn't see
it but someone said it in a book or some
rumor mill maybe but I don't know but I
know we played again and I might have
won again
oh because this story is he demolished
you I don't know about all that
but see that's why I asked the question
because I want to clear this up so then
you never have to explain it again did
Jordan ever beat you in ping-pong not
that I recall
okay if he's listening right now what
would you say to Jordan about this not
that I recall
refresh my memory but that's the only
thing I ever beat him at really did you
ever play one-on-one
I did not play everybody on the dream
team one on one and I think Michael came
out just for like one possession and he
had the ball and I had a garden how'd
that go it didn't go away but I remember
I remember and again in a practice
situation we were playing at five on
five and I caught the ball at the top of
the key and I looked and Michael was in
front of me and I said man he's so quick
he's gonna go for any fake so I faked
him left and I actually got by him and
as I am going to myself oh my god I got
by Michael Jordan as I'm saying I got by
Michael Jordan I go up for my Duncan
David Robinson's right there so it was
all over how did you did you feel like
did they make you feel like you belonged
on that dream team because you were the
only college guy they made me feel like
they wanted to see if I could act and
behave like a rookie and I was a very
good rookie I was willing to get their
coffee and their cigars in the morning
and their take their dirty laundry to
the washing machine and that that's all
they want to see that they only want to
see that you know your place
don't try to upstage anybody be a good
rookie and and they'll love you and they
did who did you want to pick the brain
of or allowed you to pick their brains
because you're getting ready to go into
the NBA well that's maybe a mistake I
made I didn't pick any other brains I
wanted to play one-on-one against them
more than anything I'm a basketball
player I love basketball I love to play
basketball I still love to play
basketball but I can't because I'm 50
years old and I'm old and it hurts
so I didn't pick their brains about but
you didn't want to know about their
approach to the game or what you needed
to learn going into the NBA no I just
wanted to play one-on-one against Larry
Bird and Magic Johnson and Chris Mullin
and Clyde Drexler and all those guys and
that's what I did and that was my
fondest memory besides representing your
country and winning a gold medal in the
Olympics things that you watch your
whole life growing up the thing that I
love
the Moses that I got to play one-on-one
against all those guys where's your gold
medal in my house in the safe yeah do
you bring it out I never bring it out
people ask for it once in a while they
want to see it but I don't bring it out
so if I come down for dinner
well you okay special okay all right
would you let me wear it I would let you
wear it yes okay but that's because
you're a legend okay thank you thank you
I think you're just saying that because
we're on TV once we go to commercial
break here you go there is no effing way
you're gonna get to wear that metal
ping-pong table thing do we have the
poll question McLovin for christian
Laettner yeah who is the most talented
not the greatest most talented player
ever Duke our choices were Christian
Laettner Grant Hill Bobby Hurley or Zion
Williamson and Grant Hill won the poll
Christian Laettner second grant he'll
definitely should win the poll people
don't remember that Grant Hill almost
averaged a triple-double for a few years
in the NBA you know I think he averaged
23 and eight and eight or 77 that's
pretty freakin good in the NBA and J
Williams was a very talented player at
Duke as well you know of course had the
motorcycle accident I think people
forget that Grant was on his way to
being a Michael Jordan liked player uh
you know or maybe a better Scottie
Pippen like he was on his way to being
something that was really really special
because we were waiting for the next
Jordan and there all these guys that
well he's the next Jordan he's the next
door I thought Grant had that
opportunity to be somebody who would go
down as one of the you know 10 15
greatest players of all time I thought
he was that talented I don't think he
was on his way I think he was there you
know I think for five or six years he
averaged like we said almost a
triple-double then I was on his team
when he broke his foot twice in one year
and the reason he broke his foot twice
in one year is that certain things and
certain people pressured him to play
when he shouldn't have played I was
there when he broke his foot the first
time yeah he shouldn't have been playing
in the playoffs when he broke his foot
foot a second time
and that injury the second break almost
caused him to lose his foot practically
where he couldn't like it got infected
you know people don't know the whole
story where he could have ended his
career right there but he fought through
seven or eight more years you know with
the magic and with the Sun well who's
pressuring him to get back to play well
I don't want to get anyone in trouble
but I was there when I heard it break
the first time I was there when I saw
people saying you got a play you got a
play for us it's just a stress fracture
doesn't matter what it is it's a break
little fracture he heard it pop I heard
a pop then he broke it a second time and
that really changed him and you know I
know that we talked about John
Williamson and how talented he is
but if you just went talent alone at
Duke where does Zion fit in with Jay
grant yourself he's different he he's
very talented there's there's 20 super
talented kids that have played at Duke
now is he the most special athletically
gifted person I've ever seen yes I've
never seen anyone on the basketball
court like him if you took Bo Jackson
and turned him six seven and put him on
the basketball court he might be close
but Zions a combo of Shaq down low when
Shaq got the ball within six feet of the
bucket there's nothing you could do
when Zion gets it down there there's not
much you can do he reminds me of LeBron
a little bit in the full court situation
and then he reminds me of Charles
Barkley in terms of how he pursues the
ball how strong he is with the ball how
bouncy he is how would you guard him I
would back way off and make him hit make
him hit ten three-pointers to score 30
points there there's no dunks no layups
nothing in the lane back off him would
you talk to him no I would not talk to
him I would say go ahead shoot that shot
right there and if you make it then
that's how you'll have to beat us but
the 21 year old Christian Laettner what
would he say to Diane Williamson if he's
gardening you know when I was 21 and
gran was a freshman
every day he walked into practice I
would throw him the ball and say come
dunk on me and I would stand right
underneath the hoop and I'd let him move
started the three-point line and I would
challenge him every day to dunk on me
and there was a certain point where that
had to stop because he was documented so
with Zion I don't think I would have
done that game because he's just too
strong he's gonna break somebody's hand
he's gonna break someone's finger who
tries the block has done cuz he's just
too much power there Paul Pierce came
out and said he thinks I owns one of the
top 50 players right now in the world is
unique I've never seen a physical
specimen quite like him he but is he a
top 50 player right now well I don't
know about that and I don't know why
everyone wants to compare and contrast
and who's the best and who's this but
that wait do you just wake up and
realize that this has been going on for
years this is what we do have a hot take
on something yes it is it's unfortunate
instead of they're not gonna let him
just go into the NBA it's gonna be well
you got average at least 20 what's wrong
with you your your average in seventeen
and seven and four and that's not gonna
be good enough for people especially if
he ends up with this franchise here in
New York I mean this media is tough
they're gonna expect greatness out of
him yeah and I don't know why why people
are like that and if everyone was an
athlete or professional athlete I don't
think they all would act like that you
know and and it's it hurts to see people
not realize that you have to put
yourself in the other person's shoes and
I'm sure I don't put myself in the media
shoes a lot but the media has to put
themselves in the athlete's shoes
sometimes also and realize that it's a
tough situation it's tough expectations
but my only hope is that Zion doesn't
get hurt for the next five years because
if he never gets hurt then we're gonna
see some unbelievable dunks some
unbelievable blocks in the NBA but if
you know what I mentioned that you were
gonna be on it's sometimes interesting
how we go
yeah but how worthy is a pro like
somehow it diminishes your college
career because you weren't great as a
pro like Tim Tebow but it doesn't it
because they said look at Laettner's
numbers in the pros I mean you had
seasons where he averaged 17 a game and
but you were in a draft where you got
Shaq and you got so and are you living
up to that and somehow that diminishes
what you did at Duke because you weren't
this Hall of Fame NBA type player and I
go you're kind of missing Johnny Manziel
no matter what he does it's still one of
the great college quarterbacks of all
time but we do look to diminish what you
did is a collegian if you're not great
in the pros it's weird that that happens
when one reason is because people the
general public and maybe the media don't
realize how good the professional
athletes are and how many beasts there
are in the NFL and how many beasts there
are in the NBA if I didn't do as good in
the NBA as people thought I could have
done or I should have done then you have
to chalk it up to being on a great team
at Duke in a great system I'll be the
first to tell you that I'm a system
player I need a strong coach I need a
good program a good system to have my
most success and it only happens in
basketball when you're surrounded by
other good players even LeBron James
can't do it by himself on the Lakers
yeah I've seen Michael Jordan and
Scottie Pippen not be able to do it the
two of them on the bowl so you have to
be surrounded by a good team and then
don't forget how good and how many
beasts there are in the NBA and yes it's
harder in the NBA and it if I didn't win
in the NBA as much as I did in college
and if I didn't have the same numbers
it's because there's more Charles Oakley
and David Robinson and Anthony Mason and
all these monsters and and it does make
it harder
can you teach the confidence you had
game on the line you wanted the ball
like the bigger the oh no you can't
teach it you only get confidence by
playing ping-pong for 10 years and
getting so good at it that you you know
you can beat anybody
you only get confidence on the
basketball court from practicing and
shooting a thousand shots and making 800
of them and saying to yourself man I'm a
good
shooter that that's the only place
confidence comes from but when you're
playing Larry Johnson or Chris Webber in
college I mean those are two really
really good players but it you'd you'd
never seem to flinch when you had a big
moment there like it wasn't a
coincidence that you were great in big
games well thanks I appreciate you
saying that um it comes from practice
like I said but it also comes from Coach
K and some of your teammates when you're
a freshman at Duke and Quin Snyder and
Danny Ferry look at you and they say we
need you bad that gives you a lot of
confidence when Coach K looks at you and
says we need you out there you're one of
our best players that gives you a ton of
confidence did Danny Ferry hate you when
you got there your freshman year of
course my first day on Duke campus what
happened my parents shot me off I kissed
them goodbye said go back to New York
and leave me alone and I walked straight
into the Duke basketball office and
Danny Ferry was there getting his mail
and he didn't even say hello to me he
just said you want to go play what I
wanted and of course I said yeah let's
go play one-on-one so like we walked
over to the locker room we got changed
he said here's your Duke practice gear
and then we went out and played
one-on-one and I had to let him be on
offense first cuz he was the senior and
he drove left and spun right and put his
elbow right in my mouth and said welcome
to ACC college basketball nice nice and
then you eventually did that to other
people and I've been crucified for it
since Danny Ferry was the guy next door
that you'd want your daughter to date
you it was you know you were different
yeah still vilified but you know people
don't hate christian Laettner
no it was I hate one person that was the
name of the the movie I hate Christian
like it was only one person oh it's not
one there's more than one that hate
Christian Laettner but my dad there was
only one Christian joining us on behalf
of Land O'Lakes which invited students
to participate in the Land O'Lakes
BOTS shot so these are robots here so
you got the brightest robots robotic
talents and Minnesota produced South
Dakota State University University of
wisconsin-madison advanced to the
championship event that'll be in
Minneapolis April 7th so the robots
shoot basketball yep Land O'Lakes sent a
box of metal parts to these seven
schools and then they picked the four
best bots that were created and and the
big event is on Sunday at De La Salle at
D LaSalle High School and we're gonna be
there taking shots with the robots but
it's all to promote you know we need
more young people involved in the
agriculture and the farming industry um
I'm up in Minnesota in North Dakota
South Dakota all the time I see all the
big farms but I don't know if all the
youngsters are getting involved they
want to be on their phone and their
computer and they got to realize that
Land O'Lakes is at the forefront of
innovation in technology using it in the
farming industry everybody gets the same
ingredients to make their robot yes and
these students then put it together and
then these robots shoot what free throws
yes they play a game of horse I got a
way of making this viral okay are you
ready I'm ready put the robot on the
floor and you step on the robots chest
he's always so big on that stopping it's
gold what about a robot that does the
stomp on you and me and then is the
robot gonna take the Kentucky shot is
the robot gonna catch anything fake
right spin left to shoot a fadeaway that
that would be good too are they gonna
leave the robot open is what I want to
know cuz you didn't even have to fake
one way and go the other way you got to
put a robot in front of that robot and
roll
that was bad defense on Kentucky's part
I mean it was a nice shot you made yes I
was very surprised that no one flew in
front of me to go after the pass and yes
that's one mistake they made but you
make a lot of mistakes in the game
you didn't make too many mistakes I made
plenty of mistakes that game but I
didn't miss any shots that well but I
had some turnovers were you like ten for
ten and then ten for 10 from the line
yes that's pretty good it's pretty good
thank you
yeah I can tell you're overcome with
emotion I haven't heard that before no
one said to me before Christian good job
Wow hey could we get a round of applause
for Christian flake poor guy hey great
to see you thank you sir four more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]